[Musica]
lo riconoscete
questo che voglio immagini di vaia
siamo nel territorio in cui questa
tempesta devastato questa regione
abbiamo avuto dei venti oltre i 200
chilometri orari di velocità
tempesta tropicale
piccolissimo dettaglio siamo sulle alpi
quindi un evento molto strano no
probabilmente molti hanno commentato
detto vabbè ma una volta ceramica più
è passato un anno acqua grande a venezia
marea record ulteriore disastro
ancora la considerazione quale siamo in
nord italia
quindi c'è qualcosa ma cosa c'è dietro
tutto questo che non funziona ma
soprattutto la provocazione che ora è
lanciare è che al di là di queste
immagini che ci hanno scioccato nel
tempo a suo tempo ovviamente ma tuttora
quando li rivediamo è che sia stato
associato
un danno a tutto questo vi dico che più
o meno non sono stati considerati circa
3 miliardi di euro
quindi io mi dico ma ha senso
quantificare con un danno economico una
devastazione ambientale
o lavorate la mia risposta è no
cioè non è pensabile che
investendo del denaro
io color oggi potesse disporre di questa
cifra di collemeto li mettiamo questi
soldi quindi ricrescono gli alberi no
quindi non è vero che è reversibile non
è sostenibile
ci siamo abituati spesso a ragionare in
termini di reazione siamo diventati
bravi occuparsi di reazione molto meno
ad occuparci di azione quindi a
prevenire le cose invece che a reagire
in fase successiva
allora noi con la nostro stile di vita
non in qualche maniera non abbiamo
capito che stiamo aggiungendo un
contenuto energetico del pianeta il
pianeta ci sta rispondendo che sta
dicendo guarda che non sarei molto
d'accordo con questo approccio
gli ho parlato di digitale quindi adesso
chiaramente c'è una tecnologia diffusa
molti ci stanno guardando da streaming
spero che qualcuno dei miei familiari lo
stia facendo
e
tenere in mano un telefonino significa
comunque
consumare energia ve ne rendete conto
banalmente avesse scarica la pila
ma qualche volta fatte un video vi
accorgete che magari facendo una
videochiamata per quanto gli si può pure
spegnere dal quale motivo ma si spegne
perché assorbe più energia magari c'è la
cover non riesce a dissipare no quindi
c'è un concetto legato al consumo di
energia e
quindi proviamo ad introdurci in questo
concetto no perché chiaramente digitale
inarrestabile e quello che ci ha
consentito il regime di pandemia di
mantenere le relazioni sociali non ci è
consentito di fare riunioni
da remoto di evitare di fare mare sei
ore di auto in mezz'ora di riunione
facciamo solo la mezz'ora di riunione
senza farle sei ore di auto
però se noi imprenditori ma dietro al
concetto energetico
per ogni chilowattora di energia che noi
produciamo
vengono immessi in atmosfera circa 300
grammi di co2 ora tanti o pochi guardate
abbiamo migliorato molto
circa 20 anni fa era il doppio la media
europea no perché mettiamo 300 grammi di
co2 per fare energia elettrica perché
abbiamo delle fonti fossili per la
produzione di energia elettrica perché
ne abbiamo e stiamo mettendo meno è
perché nel frattempo abbiamo agito bene
abbiamo utilizzato fonti energetiche
rinnovabili però ancora la situazione è
quella che vi ho descritto quindi
mettiamo comunque un gas serra ma la co2
il gas più pericoloso come effetto serra
no non è più pericoloso però è quello
che viene prodotto in maggior quantità
questa è la problematica
e che cos'è l'effetto serra verde prova
a rendermelo con un esempio abbastanza
facile
poi in estate quando andate al mare poi
tornate al parcheggio dalla vostra
automobile accaldati sia caldo fuori no
per voi sapete già cosa vi accadrà
quando aprirete la porta della vostra
auto
l'abitacolo sarà surriscaldato
a cosa è dovuto questo è dovuto al fatto
che il parabrezza provati da immaginarlo
come una rete a maglia sottile la
radiazione ultravioletta che arriva dal
sole a un'altra pensare relativamente
elevata quindi una lunghezza d'onda
piccola così piccola che lascia passare
attraverso questa rete a maglia sottile
poi colpisce i sedili venneri emessa nel
campo dell'infrarosso delle basse
temperature
la lunghezza non è molto più lunga lei
vorrebbe anche uscire dal parabrezza ma
rimane intrappolata perché lei è più
grande della dimensione maglia e quindi
si surriscalda l'apparecchio c'entra
qualcosa ma non entrano non esce nulla
dell'automobile questo è l'effetto serra
e che comporta quindi un
surriscaldamento del pianeta quindi noi
nell'emettere gas serra come se
contassimo un parabrezza attorno al
nostro pianeta
se parliamo in termini di una famiglia
media italiana quattro persone
questo comporta più o meno un consumo
energetico di circa
4.000 34 mila kilowattora all'anno
questi cosa comportano in termini di
footprint quella cosa guardate le mie
spalle
cioè circa una tonnellata di co2 quanto
grande è noto nella tra di co2 che la
sfera di circa 10 metri di diametro
e tanto poco è quella lì cioè quello è
il nostro impatto quindi noi dobbiamo
incominciare a pensare come potremmo con
le nostre azioni provare a ridurre
queste
queste emissioni anche partendo da
piccole azioni non faccio questo esempio
qui che è abbastanza rappresentativo
inviare una mail da un mega che tutto
sommato non è un gran che comunque
comporta un emissione in diretta di co2
di circa 19 grammi di co2
questo se non lo provassimo a proiettare
su un'azienda di 50 persone e ciascuno
dei quali ma di venti medi questo tipo
che non sono niente di che
comporterebbero un emissione di circa 20
kg di co2 in una giornata ora questo per
dire cosa per dire che magari anche
piccolissimi azioni del tipo ne mando
menomando un link che spedire il video
200 persone quando un league si dovevano
vedere sull'unico serio in cui essere
disponibile
ovviamente molti di voi probabilmente
saranno dicendo ma possibile che sia la
mia mail quella che
comporta un cambiamento climatico la
risposta è no
e chiaro che non è così no però mi piace
ricordare che le grandi cose che stanno
a una pseudo vieta ma insomma le grandi
cose sono fatte di piccole cose
immaginatevi la muraglia cinese era
stata leggermente recentemente recensita
in 8.850 chilometri di lunghezza sarà
fatta di mattoni i mattoni sono piccoli
però sono tanti e dallo spazio la vedete
l'unica cosa che si vede della terra
allora mi viene da pensare o vi invito a
riflettere su questo che comunque tutta
l'energia che noi generiamo che
l'utilizzo di tecniche informatiche
comporta bene comunque poi alla fine
concentrata non c'è il vostro telefono
non è indipendente da una rete fa parte
di una rete quindi questi dati poi vanno
avanti vengono concentrati vengono
raccolti vanno a finire in enormi
strutture che sono i data center
addirittura adesso ai per skate data
center tenete presente che una di queste
infrastrutture a potenze elettriche
assorbite dell'ordine delle decine di
megawatt un mega watt sono 1000 kilowatt
1000 kilowatt sono 400 famiglie italiane
sto per darvi solo un'idea
grandi linee allora allora mi viene da
pensare e di dire ma se noi torniamo
indietro nella nostra è una regione sul
territorio e cultura che conta di nano i
nostri i miei nonni
poi mi avete sentito quella che voi non
siamo l'esempio del maiale si diceva del
maiale non si butta via nulla
allora proviamo a ragionare nello stesso
modo noi abbiamo fatto da tempo rete
energetica quindi kobe l energia
elettrica e una rete
rete internet i dati su una rete è
pensabile
proporre una rete energetica e per
condividerla meno in qualche maniera no
ma la risposta è sì è sì perché
un grande data sente una grande
concentrazione di dati comporta un
impiego di potenza elettrica enorme che
poi deve venire smaltita dai server
quindi raffreddati quindi ulteriore
potenza per smaltire il calore generato
e tutto questo viene rigettato
nell'ambiente
è possibile pensare di riutilizzarlo per
esempio che fare reti di
teleriscaldamento
la risposta è sì è possibile farlo è
nuova questa idea non è nuova è solo che
non è strutturale viene fatta qua e là
mentre invece questo deve richiedere un
cambio di marcia di paradigma di dire no
quando si fa infrastruttura visto che il
digitale inarrestabile va pensato
integrato con uno sviluppo urbanistico
e quindi bisogna pensare introdurre
delle strutture che possono recuperare
questo calore ed evitare che poi le
abitazioni consumi in un ulteriore
energia che metterà ulteriore co2
inutile perché devono riscaldarci
un'altra volta quando si potrebbero
scaldare con quello emesso dal data
center
questo è un ragionamento che richiede
logica infrastrutturale guardate questa
una enorme opportunità in questo momento
anche per il nostro paese perché grazie
ad alcune
idee futuriste illuminate per l'italian
tipo la break sit
mondo dell'information technology in
europa si articolava su una parola cara
flap frankfort london paris amsterdam
adesso questa parola è diventata
impronunciabile flap
m sta per milano cioè milano sta
diventando una direttrice importante
d'italia in particolare quindi questo e
questo deve portare deve portare dire
usiamo la testa non spingiamo oltre
iniziamo a pensare a un'organizzazione
integrata non si può fare delle case le
farò lì vicino 9 faccio lontano perché
le distanze dal fattore discriminante in
questo non riusciva a rendere efficaci
queste tecnologie allora anche qua
un'altra volta non lo potrebbe vietare
direbbe bravo facile inverno altro gol
abbiamo risolto ed estate
cosa facciamo
ma in estate si può fare il
teleraffreddamento sì che si può fare è
più difficile ma certo che più difficile
ma ci sono le tecnologie si possono
utilizzare cicli integrati di pompe di
calore ad alta efficienza più cicli ad
assorbimento non voglia di aventi di
tanto abbiamo il signor secondo
principio della termodinamica
che perdonato il mio parentesi genieri
stica che ci rompe molto le scatole a
riguardo ai visti in may 89 minuti che
ho a disposizione sono già 10 e 40 kg
sta sforando
non è possibile andare oltre ma bisogna
darsi queste sfide e bisogna sicuramente
pensare che non può essere che un
problema complesso avevano soluzione
facile e quindi bisogna lavorare questa
direzione credici dal suo obiettivo
ambizioso e vi garantisco che è
possibile anche perché se consideriamo
che il consumo medio di energia pro
capite
mondiale in generale non elettrica in
generale è di 2,4 megawattora a testa
anche qui però ma dov'è il problema è
che due paesi del nord america canada
stati uniti e due paesi europei svezia
norvegia hanno un consumo pro capite di
24 c 10 volte di più ma non del più
sfortunato di quello medio
quindi se noi andassimo da un cittadino
del burundi che è il paese al mondo che
ha il minor pil pro capite del mondo gli
chiedessimo tu vuoi vivere come un
cittadino svedese secondo me questo
risponderà risponderà senz'altro sì che
voglio vivere come un cittadino svedese
ma l'altra domanda è ma è possibile
questo è la risposta è no non è
possibile perché non è sostenibile
e allora qual è la soluzione andare
dallo svedese dvd peggio perché così
vive meglio quello del burundi anche lui
della manovra perché devo vivere peggio
quindi l'unica strada proprio quella di
pensare a consumare meglio a
razionalizzare l'utilizzo e tornare il
concetto del maiale le cose difficili ci
porteranno soluzioni per problemi
complessi questa è la strada che io
voglio indicare anche perché la strada
della sostenibilità guardate che non è
una delle possibili ma è l'unica
possibile affinché le nostre generazioni
miei figli i miei probabili nipoti potrà
possono vivere una realtà come quella
che noi di cui noi godiamo oggi io
ringrazio tutti recanti